ما بي
حيل اصبرتك
[موسيقى]
دي اغنيه الحنين الى بغداد وقصائد تتغزل
بها يستذكر البغداديون يوم تاسيس مدينتهم
والذي منحها لقب مدينه السلام قبل اكثر من
1200 سنه
بالمجد ليس تطالب يستذكر البغداديون يوم
تاسيس مدينتهم بفرحه يشوبها الكثير من
الحزن والاسباب تتلخص بما يعيشونه فيها
لا تزال ترغب في ان يكون للمجد بنيان جديد
بنيان من خلال الديمقراطيه المجوده بنيان
من خلال همم ايجاد فسح اكبر من الامل
ورمز للتاريخ ورمز الانسانيه
وتبقى بغداد صامده
وما تعانيه من ضمن من العالم
بغداد على بعض المؤسسات الثقافيه هنا
يتقدمها سنويا نادي الصيد العراقي اكثر
النوادي الثقافيه الاجتماعيه في العاصمه
العراقيه
فين في نادي الصيد انه نحن نقوم بمقام
الدوله يعني نقوم بعمل الدوله المفروض
تقوم هكذا تحتفي ببغداد بكافه همم اروقه
بغداد بكافه محلات بغداد
من كل عام على الرغم من ان يوم تاسيسها
الفعلي يعود الى شهر نيسان ابرز الاختلاف
بين الموعدن مرتبط بقضايا سياسيه لا يكترث
اغلب البغداديين لها الشتاء
[موسيقى]